DAVID SHIROKOFF: Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
So today, I'd like to tackle
a problem on direction fields.
So given a
differential equation,
y prime equals
negative y divided
by x squared plus
y squared, we're
asked to first sketch
the direction field.
And then secondly,
given the curve
that goes through
y(0) equal to 1,
we're asked several
questions about it.
Why is y of x greater than
0 for x greater than 0?
And then, why is
y of x decreasing
for x greater than 0?
So I'll let you think about this
for a moment and I'll get back.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back.
OK, so to start
off this problem,
we're asked to sketch
the direction field.
Now when asked to sketch
a direction field,
the first thing to do is to
look at a couple isoclines.
So what is an isocline?
Well, it's a curve
where the derivative y
prime is equal to m,
which is some constant.
So what are the isoclines for
this differential equation?
Well, it would be minus
y divided by x squared
plus y squared equals m.
Now, of particular
interest, there's
a very special isocline, which
is usually the easiest to plot.
And that's a nullcline.
And this is just a special
case where m is equal to 0.
So what's the
nullcline for this ODE?
Well, when m is equal to 0, the
only way that y prime can be 0
is when y is 0.
So the nullcline for
this ODE is y equals 0.
Now, for more general
isoclines, we're
left with this relation
between x and y.
And we can massage
this expression
to see exactly what
the isoclines are.
So specifically, I'm
going to multiply through
by x squared plus y squared,
and I'm going to divide by m.
And we see that we have
a quadratic in x and y.
And we have one linear term.
So whenever we have
a relation like this
and we want to understand
what it looks like,
typically the approach is
just to complete the square.
So I'm going to
bring the 1 over m y
to the other side
of the equation.
And I'm going to
combine it with y
squared to complete the square.
And when we do this, we
obtain the following equation.
And we recognize this equation
as the equation for a circle.
Specifically, it's
a circle that's
centered at x is equal to 0
and y is equal to negative 1
over 2m.
And in addition, the
circle has a radius
r squared is equal to 1
over 4m squared, which
means its radius is 1 over 2
times the absolute value of m.
OK, so why don't we take a look
and plot a couple isoclines?
So as I mentioned before,
typically the first isocline
that we should plot
is the nullcline,
which is m is equal to 0.
And we know that this
is y is equal to 0.
So all along the
line y is equal to 0,
I'm just going to draw dashes
that correspond to a slope of y
is equal to 0.
For the other isoclines, we just
have to pick some values of m
and start plotting.
So I'll take the value m
is equal to negative 1.
And when m is equal
to negative 1,
we have a circle which
is centered at 0 and 1/2
with radius 1/2.
So here's 1/2.
Here's 1.
And at every point
along the circle,
we just draw a little
slope of negative 1.
So at every point
along this curve,
the solution has
slope negative 1.
Now, in addition, we can also
get another circle, which
is centered at negative 1/2.
And this corresponds
to the isocline of m
is equal to plus 1.
And every point on this
circle has slope plus 1.
Those should all be the same.
And now we can pick
some other values of m.
So for example, m is equal to 2.
If m is equal to 2,
then we have a circle
which is centered at
negative 1/4 and radius 1/4.
So it might look
something like this.
And m is equal to negative 2
might look something like this.
So this is m is
equal to negative 2.
This is m is equal to 2.
And the slope on this curve
is going to be steeper.
It's going to be negative 2.
And the same goes
for this circle.
And then lastly, I
can draw a sketch of m
is equal to 3/4, which would
go up something like this.
Sorry, m is equal
to negative 3/4.
And that would have a slightly
weaker slope like this.
So notice how the
collection of isoclines
are a family of circles that
all are tangent to the origin.
And in fact, if
we think about it,
the nullcline, the
m equal 0 line,
is actually, in
some sense, a limit
circle where we take the
radius in the center going
to infinity.
So as the circles become
larger and larger,
they tend to approach
this line y equals 0.
So this concludes part one.
So for part two, we're now
asked several questions
about the curve which goes
through y(0) is equal to 1.
So I'll just sketch what this
solution curve might look like.
And it's going to start off
at a slope of negative 1.
And then it's going to
hit these circles, which
have a steeper slope.
And then eventually
it's going to go
through the circles
with a steeper slope
and come back to the circle
that has slope negative 1.
And eventually, decay outwards.
So this is what the solution
curve might look like.
I'm just sketching this to
set up parts 2a and 2b here.
OK, so why is y of x
always bigger than 0
for x greater than 0?
Well, we see that
this solution curve
stays in the upper half plane.
And we note that y is equal
to 0, which is the nullcline,
is actually a very
special curve.
Not only is it the nullcline,
but it's actually a solution
to the differential equation.
So if we look back at the
differential equation,
we see that y is equal
to 0 has zero derivative.
And the right-hand side of
the differential equation
is also 0.
So this is not only a
nullcline, but it's a solution
to the differential equation.
Note that this is
extremely special.
In no way does
every nullcline have
to be a solution to a
differential equation.
But in this case, we get lucky.
Now we know from
the theory of ODEs
that solution
curves can't cross.
So a solution curve that
starts in the upper half plane
can't cross another
solution, which in this case
is the y equals 0 curve.
Hence, it must be
bounded in the upper half
plane for all x bigger than 0.
The second part, why
is y of x decreasing
for x greater than 0?
Well, what we have
to look at-- so
I'll just write in here part 2.
We have to look at
the sign of y prime.
Now y prime is equal
to negative y divided
by x squared plus y squared.
So as I've just
argued, a solution
that starts in the
upper half plane
and goes through the point
y of 0 is equal to 1,
stays in the upper half plane
for all x bigger than 0.
What this means is
that the solution curve
has y bigger than 0 for
all x bigger than 0.
So that means the numerator
is always positive.
The denominator is
also always positive.
So we have negative
a positive number
divided by a positive number.
And so this quantity is always
going to be less than 0.
So for x bigger than
0, y prime is always
going to be less than 0.
Hence, the solution
that starts at y of 0
is equal to 1 is going to
monotonically decay to y
is equal to 0.
OK?
So this concludes the problem.
Now just to recap,
we were given an ODE.
The standard approach when
sketching direction fields
is to pick a few nullclines.
Or to pick a few isoclines.
And specifically
pick the nullcline.
Sketch the isoclines.
And then, if you're asked
to plot any integral curves
or solutions to the
differential equation,
you just simply
connect the dots.
OK, so I'd like
to conclude here,
and I'll see you next time.